I'm uh Dr Anand Narayanan but please
call me sunny
so I started my journey as a scientist
with interest in biology but also
fascinated with
with NASA and our human space
exploration program so complete my
doctoral training at Texas A M
University studying that very question
what happens to biology when it is
exposed to the space line environment my
family is originally from
apart from Northern India from Delhi
large diverse and bustling City and then
my father's side from rural Southern
India
and my father was very much an
adventurer he traveled young in his life
wound up in Germany and met my mother
who was from totally a different part of
India and who was also very much an
artist in her in her own way but neither
of them were had extensive educational
academic training I grew up in Germany
and growing up I recall our trips across
Europe so that was uh when I was a kid
and there was a a moment my my parents
profession where they recognized that
for myself my younger brother for us to
achieve the opportunities that we had an
interest those opportunities we best
attained to moving to America to the
United States
and we
immigrated to West Virginia Morgantown
uh colushan very much an academic center
for the state of West Virginia and also
had a very uh strong connection with
the with the space program there was a
NASA Center 30 minutes away I grew up
hearing stories of Homer Hickam and
Chuck Yeager and various individuals
that had strong ties to our human space
exploration program if I had not heard
or seen those stories or
those programs or opportunities I
speculate my
scientific Journey would have been very
different I recognize that a lot of my
experiences and uh how I got involved
with acne was uh was location dependent